all right let's talk about canada for a
minute canada's become a huge mess you
know australia seems to be like the the
coveted mess beyond imagination i mean
they've got troops in the streets it's
actually just completely insane what's
going on in australia we've talked about
a little bit on this show you don't see
any of it on mainstream because they
don't want you to know that other
countries are even more draconian than
us because it might wake us up to what
could be coming for us right so you
never see it on cnn or anywhere else
obviously
you know just literally people walking
their dogs and being assaulted by police
officers old women being choked in the
name of health i mean this is literally
what's going on in australia but canada
has also gone into just
borderline police state at this point um
if you want a little more info on this
uh you should watch our friday panel
show from two weeks ago uh we had ezreal
event from the rebel and lauren chen and
uh who else was on there oh and uh viva
fry of course um who at the time was
running for uh a seat in parliament
uh in any event it's a mess it's a
freaking mess up there they're closing
churches they're not letting people out
they have
they're they have troops on the streets
and they're locking people down i mean
the whole thing it's all there and the
video is out there online for now
here is video of alberta premier jason
kenny
talking about restrictions for canadian
thanksgiving
this weekend of course is thanksgiving a
time when family and friends gather
so my message is simple
please follow the rules that are in
place
to be blunt
no indoor social gatherings are
permitted outside of a household for
people who are unvaccinated for those
who are vaccinated indoor social
gatherings are limited to two households
for up to 10 people who are age 12 or
older
we are also lowering the maximum number
of people permitted to participate in
outdoor social gatherings from 200 to
20.
all right so i'm not going to sit here
and tell you that i have a tremendous
amount of knowledge about jason kenny
but if you want to pretend that that
dirt bag isn't going to violate his own
edicts uh you can but he obviously will
and i'm sure he does and i'm sure he's
getting together with plenty of people
and i'm sure they're not wearing masks
and he knows that it's all nonsense
interestingly there he said please
follow the rules so first it's nice to
say please right you got to teach the
young people you should say please be
respectful but or what
i didn't get to the or what part are you
going to start arresting people who dare
have canadian thanksgiving with 11
adults
or 9 adults and 3 children above 12
and what happened to two weeks to
flatten the curve
and what right do you have to tell
people how many people they can get
together with and what right do you have
to demand that anyone who's hosting
thanksgiving at their house
ask anyone else what their medical
status is
we have completely folks completely
outsourced our logic and our reason
and our defense of privacy and your
ability to make decisions for yourself i
i just i'm i'm absolutely shocked uh
calgary's in alberta right can you
confirm that i'm 99 sure it is that this
is western canada if i'm not mistaken
can i get in
uh because if it is in
alberta i'm pretty sure it is calgary's
in alberta um it is yeah um i've been to
calgary a few times um and twice we went
there with the jordan peterson tour and
they were two of the 10 best shows that
we did this was such a group of fun
loving freedom-loving people the crowds
were nuts like the crowds actually the
ovations were huge it was like a running
joke about like i i could barely talk
because the crowds were screaming and i
was doing a ton of crowd work like
that's i think the spirit of of calgary
like western canada it's a little freer
there we like our freedom we have more
space we don't like the government
involved in everything it's not like
eastern canada right like i think that's
the spirit of western canada horse
country the tundra all of the stuff but
what is happening what is absolutely
happening well now uh jason kenny the
alberta premier he's also going to pay
off if you haven't got the vaccine the
delta variant of covet 19
is causing concerning rises and
hospitalizations in our province
vaccinations have stalled in alberta and
to change that anyone who gets the shot
in the coming days now gets a bonus if
you just haven't gotten around to it for
the love of god please get vaccinated
now
and if you do we will now pay you a
hundred dollars
a hundred dollars you mean i've been
listening to the news for all of these
months i've made decisions on my own i
maybe work at home and i don't go out
that much or i'm young and healthy
you're going to give me a hundred
dollars you're saying i could get call
of duty and and uh well that's about 60
what can i get for 40 bucks what are
what are people what are the young
people buying for forty dollars i could
get some soda pop and you know some
chips
like they're how does anyone believe any
of these people at this point
and and the bigger issue is these your
own your medical choices guys have
nothing to do with the government do
what is right for yourself